[Music]
thank you very much for your kind
introduction I'll be talking about
climate change science and policy
aspects of it but I will spend a few
minutes first just talking about
stratospheric ozone what led to the
Nobel Prize that I was rewarded with it
was of course a huge honour to to
receive it I I should just say I gave a
similar lecture yesterday I know there
are just a couple of you that heard me
already I thought I could give a
different lecture today but the only way
I could do that is if I give it in
Spanish so I apologize but I'm actually
going to use the same or similar view
graphs so if what I want to do is to put
in context the the research that I
carried out with my colleague sherry
Rowland we were at the University of
California at Irvine this was in early
1970s and at that time I had just
finished my PhD at the University of
California Berkeley but I have met shell
Roland already because we were both
doing very fundamental research on
chemical reactions trying to understand
chemical reactions at the very
fundamental level using quantum
mechanics and so on and so forth but we
both decided when I came to work with
him to work on something that was a
little bit closer to some societal
problem to something that which we could
apply these fundamental science
understanding that we have developed and
so we decided to learn about the
atmosphere to the atmospheric chemistry
which at that time it was not a
very well-developed discipline we had a
few colleagues that we had made that
we're working on that but what we
decided let's work on how do we do that
let's work on a problem that we think
it's interesting out of sheer curiosity
see whether we can solve it and in that
way learn about how the atmosphere
functions particularly some of its
chemical properties so that's how we
started let me give you sort of a little
bit of the background and this is going
a little over the century ago how
electric refrigeration became became to
be of course very common very useful
first in developed countries but then
eventually everywhere and that's using
electrical refrigerators now some of you
might know before that how did people
deal with refrigeration because that was
already in use in the nineteenth century
but it was typically only more wealthy
people but there was a big industry that
had been developed the way it worked is
by importing large chunks of ice from
frozen lakes at northern latitudes
that's a way refrigeration work before
the electric refrigerators came on board
and so it was maybe easier to have
refrigerators here at these latitudes
and it was in Southern California or in
Mexico okay but that's what nevertheless
this worked very well how does a
refrigerator work what you need a
refrigerant which is a fluid that with
medicinal electricity with an electric
motor you can compress it as a liquid
and then you make this liquid move
through the freezer and evaporate as it
evaporated cools
and then the gas at is formed you
compress again to form a liquid and so
on so it's a very simple idea there are
other ways to do that but this was a
very effective way what it had a problem
namely that the refrigerants that were
in use originally were sort of nasty
chemicals sold for dioxide and ammonia
and so there were the number of
accidents went home refrigerators broke
down and leaked and people had to breed
these gases that was of course it led to
some accidents and so chemists developed
new chemicals they were called at a time
miracle chemicals that could be used as
refrigerants but in some way not
poisonous and so the chemical industry
developed is so called
chlorofluorocarbons you can see here the
formulas but the important thing about
this chemicals is that they are very
inert very stable they also evaporate
and so they can be used as refrigerants
but you can breathe them they're so
inert that they don't change you can
breathe them and nothing happens as
early as opposed to ammonia and because
of that they could be used also as
propellants in spray cans which you
certainly cannot have something like
sulphur dioxide yeah because it would be
a little stinky ok but also very harmful
and spray cans became very popular
particularly in the United States
because the Inglis many things were
sprayed from toothpaste cleaners and so
on and so that's how this problem arose
because we had them a coalition Lovelock
who had developed a very special
instrument an electron capture gas
chromatograph and he was able to measure
the presence of this CFCs these
refrigerants in the atmosphere I turns
out not just in the northern hemisphere
but even
in the southern hemisphere for they were
actually not produced but clearly these
compounds were mixing all over the
planets that's why we have a global
issue with this with this compound well
I'm not going to give you a lot more
details other than Cheryl Rowland and I
then decided to investigate what's the
fate of these compounds in the
environment and we realized they were
very stable and they were going to
eventually to diffuse into the
stratosphere that's a layer above the
troposphere the lowest layer that we
have in the atmosphere at sufficient
altitudes so that just like molecular
oxygen or co2 that we all know at high
altitudes solar radiation of very short
wavelengths breaks the molecule apart
and making oxygen atoms so the CFCs at
sufficiently high altitudes would also
break down and release chlorine atoms
and what we then sort of postulated
because we knew that from the elemental
chemistry is that chlorine atoms react
very fast with ozone and the product
chlorine oxide reacts again so you
recover the chlorine atom so the bottom
line is that we have a catalytic cycle
the single chlorine atom which is
recovered deployed with this mechanism
can destroy tens of thousands of ozone
molecules and what Saul zone ozone is
warned again by this breaking molecular
oxygen but it makes this layer the ozone
layer in the stratosphere 30 to 50
kilometers sort of above the surface
mainly but it shields us from short
wavelength radiation that comes from the
Sun that is very harmful to a number of
living creatures but among others
ourselves humans if you get the short
wavelength radiation your skin it breaks
down DNA there are some repair
mechanisms but sometimes they don't work
well and you get skin cancer so that's
one of the issues that that happened if
you affect the ozone layer and
so that was our theory but we based it
our colleague Paul Crutzen with whom we
shared the Nobel Prize he had earlier
sort of discovered or or suggested how
the natural ozone layer is controlled
and that's with natural amounts of
nitric oxide with a similar catalytic
mechanism and so we were able to also
work with him and with the other members
of the scientific community that knew
others were working on the stratosphere
and essentially it appeared that the
science was well understood and that's
why we then published a paper in Nature
suggesting that the release of chlorine
atoms would eventually be pleat this
ozone layer and that it's something we
should try to avoid not together a large
hell problem for humanity and for all
the species as well but it turns out
although we had not anticipated it early
on but over Antarctica something very
special was happening so something very
spectacular namely only over Antarctica
in the spring months which is September
October at all in the southern
hemisphere the ozone layer was beginning
to be affected not in the first few
years which was in the 1970s when we
first came up with these theories but in
the 1990s now we understand why because
it's a very nonlinear effect I won't
bother you with the details of the
chemistry but it it's two chlorine
monoxide molecules reacting with each
other so the effect is proportional to
the square of the chlorine concentration
but what happens you can see here is an
in a matter of weeks over Antarctica in
the spring months and again only
starting in the 1980s not before that
also was disappearing but quite fast and
in altitudes where it's not only most
abundant more than 98 99 percent of the
ozone
was reacting away so that's what we now
label the ozone hole and over the Arctic
it something happens for not quite as
dramatic we now understand why because
Antarctica gets much colder because the
topography of the planet works in such a
way that the polar vortex is much more
stable in the south where you have a
continent of high-altitude was
surrounded by flat oceans whereas in the
North it's the other way around you have
a flat ocean which is normally ice
surrounded by continent so the vortex is
not a stable and the bottom line is an
Antarctic is a place for the
stratosphere and in fact anywhere
close to the surface is at the lowest
temperature minus 80 degrees Celsius or
so and we also now understand how the
chemistry from ice particles formed that
accelerate is the structure so the
science became very well-established we
had some measurements that indicated
really with with with a lot of
confidence that it was indeed indeed the
CFCs that were causing this problem and
not a natural effect but what was
particularly encouraging is that we
started even before the ozone hole was
there we started to work with not just
with the scientific community but trying
to communicate this problem to society
because I remember sherry and I sort of
asking ourselves what should we do now
that we face this global problem that
might have some social consequences
consequences for society if not us who
if not now then when
so we went all out and communicated that
most importantly to decision makers in
government to the public in general and
eventually also to diplomats and
fortunately we were able to convince
heads of state and through the United
Nations an agreement was reached the
Montreal Protocol and which practically
all the nations in the plan
it's agreed to stop manufacturing these
chemicals and by that time the chemical
industry very much agreed with us as
well and they were producing other
chemicals that we now use as
refrigerants you don't have to use CFCs
anymore and because of the Montreal
Protocol we now know that the ozone
layer is recovering it's a slow process
because the CFCs are still damaging this
the stratosphere those that were emitted
in the 20th century because they remain
in the atmosphere for many decades but
clearly measurements are indicating that
the ozone layer is already recovering so
we have a very big success story with
this issue so let me now switch to
climate change and I'm going to start
the gate putting this in context with
sustainable development which is as you
can read it here it's it's development
that meets the need of the present
without compromising the ability of
future generations to meet their own
needs that was grown by the West
Brundtland Commission is prominent in
prime minister in in in Norway at that
time and what I would just correct now
is that sustainable development nowadays
also means worrying about our own
generation because we're already seeing
happening not just problems for the
future but problems that are affecting
us nowadays and before I start with time
a change give you some indication that
there are many other problems as
scientific community has identified at
least eight or nine problems that they
call parts of the planet boundary namely
issues that affect the entire planet
that we should be worrying about but
what is interesting is that if you look
at Industrial Development you look at
the how particularly because technology
advanced a lot it is in the second half
of the 20th century that industry really
suddenly began to develop very fast and
one of these issues is the release of
carbon dioxide which results from
burning fossil fuels and but this is a
consequence of all these changes in
economic terms population GDP fertiliser
consumption paper production
what-have-you at least the all these
issues there's something peculiar that
you can see that these curves Bend and
that's why this is called the great
acceleration starting roughly 1950 okay
and these are the changes that worry us
why are we go into the environment where
suddenly we were affecting the ozone
layer that's one thing we have dealt
with but many other problems we have not
dealt with climate change being perhaps
the main one but because of these
changes our colleague Paul Crutzen in
particular has sort of put on the table
this issue that we are in a new
geological era which is called the
Anthropocene
ok we're no longer live in a geological
earrin like the past where the changes
had to do with periodic changes perhaps
in the Earth's orbit that causes ice
ages or large volcanoes erupting or what
have you
the the big changes nowadays clearly
come from human activities hence the
name Anthropocene okay yeah and one
suggestion is that this new era really
starts around 1950 because of this
acceleration that I just pointed out
anyhow there are that issues besides
climate change such as the nitrogen and
current and forceful recycles
one very worrisome one has to do with
with with species disappearing okay from
so we have a historically something like
five big extinctions for many biological
species disappeared because of some
something big happening like a large
meteor landing somewhere close to none
to the Yucatan Peninsula in Mexico and
that's what killed the dinosaurs
so some huge events happened in the past
but now we have the entropic scene and
it's one important cause for this
biological disappearance of many
important species but I will not be
talking about this other issues let me
concentrate on just climate change and
I'll do that by talking about these
three myths these are three points in
which there is some misunderstanding
misunderstanding
particularly by the general public but
also by many politicians the first one
is the idea that all climate is very
complicated so maybe some scientists
think that something is happening or we
should worry about the climate but many
other scientists believe that's just
natural climate after all has changed in
the past so it's not clear that it's due
to human activities that's a myth why
because surveys have been carried out
very explicitly really measuring what
the experts think not what people in
general or live in the scientific
community in general for people that
work in some way whose scientific work
is connected with climate change they've
published papers and the vast majority
agrees climate change is certainly
taking place and it's different from the
changes that we have had in the past and
it's most likely the consequence of
human activities so that's what is very
well-established and such we show this I
like to expose that when these surveys
were done there were
there was this 3% of skeptics if you
want it's not the right word because we
all scientists are skeptics we don't
accept a new thing in in science until
it's very well corroborated science
after all goes with with measurements
and with reasons ok with the scientific
method where the you sort of established
whether something is happening or not
based on experiments that they reproduce
it will and so on and so forth what that
has already happens with climate change
science so there are no good
explanations of what's happening today
other than the accepted science and the
point is we understand very well what
the objections are from this 3% of now
smaller I believe of scientists that
really question this what I insist
there are many scientists that still
don't believe in this but because they
are not experts and have not looked
carefully that's what's going on what I
like to point out one of the main ways
in which the non scientists or
scientists in different specialties or
politicians they point that all
something must be wrong with climate
science they don't take into account
that climate is a complex issue just
like the human body ok we are complex
and that's why medicines don't work 100%
of the time because we're some of us are
different and so you have to talk about
probabilities and so on and so forth and
you might have sometimes a very good
theory what things remain to be
explained the same thing happens with
climate not all aspects of climate are
perfectly well understood the role of
particles for example there are still
some questions there the role of clouds
show exactly do they compensate for
climate change these are things which
require additional science research to
be carried out but it's in general well
understood what the object the people
that object sometimes they do what we
call
picking they find something wrong one
aspect I mentioned two possibilities but
that there might be some measurements
that were questionable or what-have-you
and they somehow or other make an
analogy that the science of climate
change is like a house of cards and if
you find one card somewhere that doesn't
quite fit remove it the whole thing
falls apart
that's cherry-picking that's not the way
science works it's more like this like a
puzzle and we have pieces of the puzzle
that we still have to fit together but
you can more or less figure out what's
there which is not a very sort of
harmless little kitten movie so the
bottom line is that the science is very
well-established and so I'll tell you
briefly a little bit about the science
itself I'm not going to have time to go
into much detail but first I want to
highlight we are talking about a global
problem and it's a problem with the
atmosphere which you cannot see because
the atmosphere is transparent but it's
also very thin I like to make the
analogy it's like the skin of an apple
because most of the atmosphere is is
that close to the surface above 50
hundred kilometers it becomes so thin
that people can affect climate in any
significant way anymore but if you
release some chemicals like carbon
dioxide or CFCs that are both very
long-lived
carbon dioxide in fact it has been
measured that some fraction of it
remains more than a millennium before it
somehow or other gets absorbed again at
the surface we and so the half of the
carbon dioxide that disabilities absorb
relatively rapidly but the good fraction
of it remains in the atmosphere for a
long time and the CFCs that's
goes back what original findings remain
many decades before they can get into
the stratosphere anyhow because mixing
within each hemisphere takes place in on
a time scale of a few months that's why
we talk about global problems because it
doesn't matter where these gases are
emitted they mix it throughout the
entire planet and the stratosphere the
also layer there covers the entire
planet and the climate even though it
varies of course its consequences are
local we're talking about global climate
when we're talking about these issues
that that's the problem
but what is what's happening well let me
just explain very briefly here the
following reasoning that was already
what scientists were dealing with in the
nineteenth century the question at that
time was how does the climate of our
planet come about to be and the
reasoning was look we can measure how
much energy does our planet receive from
the Sun and that's what is keeping us
warm and we know from physics and from
from some of laws of thermodynamics what
have you without going into detail but
already for millions of year our planet
is in thermal equilibrium namely it
absorbs energy from the Sun but it emits
the same amount of energy
it receives it's no longer accumulating
energy there are some energy inside the
planet put it it's very well insulated
from the surface so it doesn't affect
climate fix except when you have huge
volcanic events ok so here in this graph
we have a plot of this energy in the
which it comes in the form of
electromagnetic radiation visible
radiation our eyes evolved to see light
from the Sun and at what shorter
wavelengths is infrared radiation which
is how our planet loses but the same
amount of energy
and do you know of course that warm
bodies emit radiation we can measure a
lot in the lab and as you increase the
temperature eventually they can become
red-hot that's when they begin to emit
some visible radiation already very warm
and white hot like in incandescent bulb
then it's relief very high temperatures
and the son of is of course one of this
very high temperature but fortunately
were not that warm that's why life could
evolve and infrared light emitted by the
our planet is not visible and so you
could measure that in the laboratory and
measure the dependence of these energies
on temperature and the answer that was
first obtained by doing this balance is
that our planet should be at around
minus 18 degree Celsius that would be a
frozen planet we wouldn't be here so
that's not the case just to explain that
this initial finding of what the
temperature was was wrong because the
atmosphere however thin it is functions
as a blanket and this blanket keeps some
of this radiation coming from the
surface area as I explained in a minute
but I forgot I wanted to first explain
this is just a little bit aside the
issue but very interesting one that
these measurements that were carried out
could not be explained
early on in terms of how much infrared
radiation the bodies emit in the
laboratory or a planet in space and it
was Planck Max Planck that was able to
rationalize these equations and and
explain them in physical terms and
that's what I have in this viewgraph
this is Planck and that's the law that
he was able to explain how by inventing
nothing less than quantum mechanics you
can only explain those observations by
assuming that energy comes in packets
light comes in packets as well called
photons that Einstein also helped with
that
so this revolutionized physics of course
always said physics now and the
chemistry is quantum chemistry nowadays
biology and so on we had an enormous
change in the sciences that towards the
beginning of the 20th century what this
this all only partly sort of effects the
way we understand the climate because it
was after all already well measured in
in the in the laboratory but the point
is the following that it we do have a
blanket how does this blanket function
if you look at three these three are
roses energy coming from the Sun one of
those roses does not absorbed by the
planet is reflected by clouds or by the
surface you can have light surfaces like
snow or ice or you can have deserts like
the Sahara Desert they reflect light but
about two-thirds of the energy that
comes from the Sun gets all the way to
the surface and the atmosphere is
transparent except for the clouds of
course that reflected is transparent to
visible radiation so it makes it all the
way to the surface but then I was
explaining that at the temperatures that
we have the surface then emits in
principle it would be the same amount of
radiation except that we do have this
blanket and because the atmosphere
absorbs this infrared radiation it has
to emit about twice as much because in
the atmosphere absorbs it then yttrium
it's this radiation absorbed the
molecules in the atmosphere absorb it
then they remit this energy in all
directions roughly half upwards half
downwards that's why you have to the
surface has to meet about twice as much
half of that comes back to the surface
warming it up and the only the two
remaining arrows is what goes out to
space and so in principle you are not
accumulating energy anymore that's it
has already reached equilibrium long
time ago but this explains very clearly
how this blanket functions okay that's
the
Green has the natural greenhouse effect
just one more piece of information
interesting with Jason and atmospheres
mostly nitrogen oxygen and a little bit
of argon just about 1% of argon which is
an inert gas and these gases are all
transparent not just to visible
radiation but also to infrared so it
turns out it's only the tiny amount of
gases whose molecules have more than two
atoms like water vapor h2o of course you
know co2 and a few others like the CFCs
these are the gases that to absorb
infrared radiation and then give it the
property of of a blanket water vapor
absorbs about 3/4 of the radiation
emitted by the surface and carbon
dioxide
most of the rest but there are these
other gases besides the CFCs there's
methane and there's nitrous oxide but
the point is it's only small amount they
are measured in parts per million levels
the amount of co2 that you would have if
it were the soot condensed rather than
in the gas phase would just be a 4
millimeter thick dry ice and that's what
keeps the our planet nothing less than
33 degrees warmer then you would have in
the absence of these gases that's the
natural greenhouse effect but something
else happens the amount of water vapor
depends very much on temperature it
condenses water evaporates from the
ocean as it goes to higher altitudes the
temperature drops and the water in the
atmosphere as originally as a gas as a
vapor condenses to make clouds rain snow
and so on so if the point is the
following its carbon dioxide although
it's it's responsible for only the
remaining 1/4 of this balance if you
were to remove carbon dioxide the
atmosphere would begin to cool and water
would condense and here is what would
happened clouds you would get a lot more
of the water vapor condensing coming
back to the surface
and you would get a frozen planet so
carbon dioxide is the thermostat of the
planet and that's very well explained
also in geological timescales for ice
ages and and so on it this is sort of I
just give gave you a brief glimpse of
the physics and of a natural climate
okay just to emphasize a bit well
understood but now let's see what humans
have done and here we look at this graph
when we have carbon dioxide for the last
ten thousand years which is the Holocene
that's the geological time scale in
which human civilization has really
advanced
that's when agriculture was on the run
so on and so forth before you had ice
ages and more complicated climate that
was not you you had hunter-gatherers
before that agriculture just came in
this time period and for this time the
carbon dioxide amount was less than 250
parts per million and if you go back
even millions of years has was always
around those levels and suddenly on this
timescale it jumps and it's now at least
40 percent larger and this carrying it's
not long before it's going to be twice
as large as this has been for millions
of years what's happening that's because
you're burning fossil fuels for do the
fossil fuels come from that's from
photosynthesis you remember the cycle
you have oxygen in the atmosphere and
carbon dioxide as well and water vapor
and green plants can take carbon dioxide
water vapor in the plant itself through
photosynthesis it makes food
carbohydrates that we can eat and as we
eat them we can use them to generate
energy how they get oxidized and this
chemical energy is what we can use to
walk to run and
and so forth and what's the result of
that oxidation it's you get back the
oxygen and water vapor without
photosynthesis we would have run out of
oxygen
well this extra co2 comes from
photosynthesis but that took many
millions of years to take place and
those plants some of those will be
composed but below the the Earth's
surface giving you coal or petroleum
from oil okay so that's a there are a
lot of details known about that but
that's what happened and if if we see
what's been happening to temperature not
easy to measure but it's very clear that
you have a similar jump just in recent
years the temperature has jumped about
one degree it doesn't look like much but
we're talking about this average surface
temperature of the planet which doesn't
change very much with time if we have a
little cooling from the year eight for
the eight thousand years ago that might
have continued put long before we get a
nice ice age that might take several
tens of thousands of years if we were to
continue that way and suddenly we jump
upwards to a temperature that we haven't
seen for a long time okay for for tens
of thousands of years and of course the
question is given all this explanation
about the signs of the climate they
should be connected but how do we
evaluate that and one way to do that is
there's a group of scientists they get
together there are voluntary scientists
and about every five years they
published a report that's it
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change the IPCC they write a report
summarizing the science and their
conclusion is that indeed we're not
quite sure that the temperature changed
this caused by co2 we only can do that
can make statements in terms of
probabilities and the probability with
the last report claimed by this group is
about 95 percent so
some possibility that that time that is
changing just because by chance 5%
probability but the most likely thing is
that it's indeed caused by human
activities okay so that's the science
itself but let's look at the next myth
namely that we shouldn't worry about
this this is just something that our
children's perhaps our grandchildren
need to be concerned with because
climate changes very slowly well that's
not really the case the Arctic sea is
already melting okay and more much more
worrisome perhaps is that we have
extreme weather events heat waves that
are already killing many people and we
have also here against floods and
droughts and wildfires and so on and in
the United States in particular we saw
last year 2017 economic losses of the
order of 3 to 4 billion dollars just
caused by these events that we call the
extremes climate extremes ok and if we
do the statistics just law review here
there are many more but they are all
increasing so what science have to tell
us about this science very cautiously
but nearest 10 15 years ago say well
that's why I don't ill we have good
enough statistics but now it's very
clear there is indeed a connection and
the connection is probabilistic this
weather events were not caused by
climate change you would still have
hurricanes that have happened for some
time now what is the intensity of this
event that's why we call them extreme
events that has very clearly increased
as a function of time so that that so
much for that means but the last is a
very important one why should we worry
about fossil fuels they are so important
for the economy we cannot really touch
that because
that's how what our economies depend on
fossil fuels well that turns out to me
to be a myth as well because now we have
other ways to generate energy of course
electricity now it's it's well known
this is relatively recent just in recent
years the technology has advanced to
such a degree that now these forms of
energy wind and solar are competitive in
economic terms with fossil fuels of
course it's difficult to change society
that's one of the difficult for them to
change fast because investments have
already been made but the point is that
we can already do it and we don't need
to to sacrifice economic growth and this
sort of energy forms also generate a lot
of jobs and so on so there's no longer
an excuse that you need to subsidize
this change it is economically
competitive ok of course there are still
issues that require further
technological development such as these
are intermittent so of course solar
energy only works in the day not at
night wind energy sometimes doesn't work
but there are lots of technological
advances storing this energy and that
there are already some that are working
and many more that are being developed
so we can do it and the question then is
what has the world done about this which
is perhaps the most serious challenge
that society's facing certainly the most
serious environmental challenge but in
terms of what might happen in the future
and good news is that to begin with we
had a meeting which is organized by the
United Nations these are so called the
conference of the parties already in
2009 I was there in Copenhagen and there
were more than 120 heads of state at
that time and they all agreed there was
consensus we need to do something about
climate change heads of state all agreed
all over the planet and one way to sort
of condense these these goals what to
say let's agree that the temperature of
the planet we should try to keep it from
rising two degrees it should hopefully
rise less than two degrees Celsius I
remind you we're already halfway there
and even if we were to stop emissions
now because the planet is not yet in
equilibrium that temperature would
continue to rise for a while so we're
not that far but that's what the heads
of state agreed but not unfortunately
the people actually doing the the rules
the negotiators did not agree so not
much happens in Copenhagen what we kept
working very hard and finally in
December in the in the 2015 the Paris
agreement came about all heads of state
I was there in fact this time more than
150 they all agreed to reach to try to
reach this goal to begin with perhaps
not with measures the strong enough to
to really reach the degree but each
country coming up with voluntary
measures to reduce their emissions and
we the idea that they would meet again
in five years so in a few years that
will happen to explain what else needs
to be done so that the climate doesn't
keep changing okay and of course it's
going to be measured and so on and so
forth so that's an incredible
achievement which means it's just like a
Montreal Protocol but it's only halfway
I need it's only on its way but here is
what's happening if we look at the
missions as a function of time we see
that the two degrees line is the blue
line we are not there yet we will have
to reduce emissions mode for
dramatically the Paris Accord is sort of
half way if we do only the Paris Accord
we might get
all the way to three degrees who knows
what if we do nothing that's a big worry
that's the red line we could reach three
or five degrees okay and so what should
we do
there's another very big worry here in
the United States there are many states
California Massachusetts and that's very
much agree with this but not the central
government president Trump as you know
didn't does not want to remain on the
Paris Accord because he does not believe
in climate change wow that's a big worry
let me just tell you what does that
imply and so I'm going to show you
Eustace roulette
which is one way to explain that to the
public you don't have to be a scientist
to understand this and this came out of
the MIT group I was many years at MIT to
work with this group at the global
change Center they have a very large one
of the most complete models of the
climate of the of our planet which is
coupled to a very large model of the of
the economy of the entire planet okay
and the left rule eight corresponds to
the red line in the previous graph if we
just continue without worrying about
climate change temperature might change
three to four for it there's a red
portion there it might change more than
five degrees Wow and that's a very big
worry but we can change this was before
this was done before the Paris agreement
I need to put it up to date but the
point is that if if that all the
countries in the planet agree to do
something we can certainly avoid the red
zone okay and that's what the scientific
community strengths is I think the most
important message is not necessarily
what's the most likely change but the
fact that if we continue without
measures we will reach temperatures that
have not been reached
in our planet by minn more than 50
million years when there was no
civilization no people around that time
and was an entirely different planet
with crocodiles in the North Pole what
that happening in tens of thousands of
years with as a result of huge volcanic
eruptions very unusual in the climate
history of our planet 55 years ago this
55 million years ago sorry but this if
it if we managed to do that in just a
few decades what would be the
consequences we would have portions of
the planet uninhabitable because of the
heat waves okay people cannot survive in
places where the temperatures 50 55
degrees centigrade we would have massive
loss of agriculture how do you feed the
9 billion people that are gonna live in
the planet at that time you would have
massive migrations all these extreme
weather events some of them could go
wild because you have many
nonlinearities in the climate so the
bottom line is that we label this as an
extreme irresponsibility okay because
science is well-established we're not
talking about certain things we're
talking about risks this is accused huge
risk one in in in five of me one in ten
is already totally unacceptable they
just pointed two or three things in in
one or two more minutes but here is one
of them how did it come about that so
many people do not believe in climate
change there are of course some issues
that have to do with the Republican
Party I'll mention in a mineral first is
it turns out Naomi Oreskes is a
historian she was at this history
department in San Diego
we're not lecturing nowadays but she's
now in Harvard and she published a book
and there's now even a movie just
documenting how some interest groups
have to do with a couple of of
fossil fuel industries they had a lot of
resources it was not interested
themselves but some of the people are
financing some a couple of billionaires
in that we have here in the United
States they put a lot of money in in not
just trying to affect the elections
which they did very successfully in
certain places they put a lot of money
in the elections themselves but they put
a lot of money with the news media
trying to discredit climate science and
that's not new that had happened it's
the same company had that done that
already with smoking you know that it's
well-known that were for many years now
that smoking and not everybody that
smokes will suffer but it certainly can
affect your health what these companies
manage to put out in work were there
were Jewish and so on and so forth so
that governments did nothing about
smoking until a decade later than
science had already established that
okay so that's one aspect but it turns
out unfortunately you already mentioned
that that the Republican Party just does
not believe in this they sort of fail on
this trap but it's no longer an excuse
the scientist come is very well
established and so it's no longer
acceptable and we have this huge
population we need to do something about
it but let me just finish I'll give you
one example what was a one in five
probability me and with sometimes as you
summarized it I fly a lot because I go
from gave a number of conferences and so
on and occasionally the pilot comes on
board when you're already on the plane
ready to take off and say we're sorry we
have a technical problem we're gonna
have to fix it
wait might take a couple of hours but we
just need to fix it but once a very
adventurous pile of we have a technical
problem I know we would have to spend
several hours to fix it I know you are
in a rush
so don't worry what I'm gonna take off
anyhow don't worry
only one if I probabilities we won't
make it to be who would like thank you
for your attention
yeah thank you very much indeed Mario hi
I'm Adam Smith from noble media and it's
my pleasure to moderate now a Q&A
session with Mario after his lecture we
have some time for questions and I do
hope you'll take the chance to us some
and there's a hand gone up already I
love it great
so please far away Mario if you're ready
yes hey so yesterday one of the
panelists said that there were numerous
grand challenges that we need to face in
order to survive as a species and
climate change was special in that it
managed to enter the consciousness of
the general population and my question
is what you think that the climate
science community did that allowed it to
make so much progress compared to
potentially other branches that did not
succeed as well then we make sure I
understand the question is now if I time
I change is special yes why is climate
change special in public consciousness
as opposed to all the other Grand
Challenges it's the one that really has
touched all public there have been a few
efforts by the scientific community I've
been part of a few of them I mentioned
one which I didn't have time to explain
here which is this one of planetary
boundaries in which the what they are
trying to talk about these problems that
affect the entire planet of course you
have a lot of local problems air
pollution is is one of those poor in
terms of issues affecting the entire
planet they have been identified by this
group and then many others have
published around that and just
established trying to measure what's
wrong at what can we do and so on and so
forth well it turns out that some of
those
worry sir are not yet sufficiently well
understood and they remain to be further
investigated and scientists recognize
that they have to do with chemical
pollution there are certain chemicals
that are known to affect locally very
harshly the environment but how is that
going to spread out that's that's one
issue other things like the phosphorus
cycle yes we can do something about it
were you using fertilizers far too much
and it causes dead zones in the ocean so
anyhow the point is that one of the most
worrisome what I would say clearly the
most worrisome one is climate change
because we are already seeing enormous
damage it's costing to the United States
itself between two and three billion
last year just for the Curie gains and
another billion because of the forest
fire so you can actually measure the
damage but with a warning I'm a good
friend of Nick Stern who's an economist
that has been very active quantifying
the damage and he had some economic
measures early on that helped with the
Copenhagen Accord and so on but one of
his last reports would I very much agree
with him is that the damage has been
grossly underestimated and you cannot
measure it in dollars only how do you
how much does it cost to have 300,000
people perish in in a heatwave what's
the cost well will be it's a moral issue
so I want to stress perhaps this is my
opportunity which I've known that
science doesn't tell us what to do
science only tell us what would happen
but we have moral commitments we have
values and we want to make sure that
future generations have the same options
that we have in this generation to have
a reasonable standard of living and so
on and so forth so that's why climate
change is a huge issue because we're
talking about enormous changes in
society okay that we that can be well
documented and if one issue where
science is very well established were
not making progress
what do you expect of the other issues
now fortunately air quality's just a
good example of something that we can
mix with climate change as is happening
in China in Mexico as well as well so at
the same time that you fix the air you
can you fix emissions by not building
more coal-fired power plants for example
so that's one response put it the
science is sort of tells us doesn't mean
we should only worry about time a change
that should be we have to worry about
everything if whenever it's time thanks
can you just wait for the microphone
Thanks question I have is there there is
indeed a great deal of consensus about
the effect of climate change to me it
doesn't seem that there is the same
consensus about the solution there's a
lot of people who believe that the use
of renewable energies won't work I'm
sure you're familiar with the paper that
was put out by by the American climate
scientists who said that one of them
used a pejorative term about climate
about renewable energy being believing
in in the tooth fairy Jim Hansen said
that and my point is how do we decide
which is the right track when there are
some people telling us renewable
energies those correct paths the other
ones saying no we've got to use
alternative particularly nuclear energy
yes well let me give you a couple of
answers first that was an unusual paper
it has been debated and I believe it by
many industries let alone scientists
it's many industries that are
specialized in energy when fossil fuel
and in the disagree with that because
it's very clear you can see the the
percentage of energy going from from
these renewable sources increasing
rapidly but most importantly that's what
is not taking into account there is that
the pop reactions they it's they are not
that difficult technologically ok so if
there is a sort of consensus that in
years I have to be a chemical engineer
myself or so but engineers will be able
to solve that the problem is political
okay so it is possible but nuclear
energy certainly should be on the table
that's much more debatable you see what
happened in Germany but again much of my
what I know about the energy perspective
of it I get from a my team some part of
this there's an MIT Energy Initiative
and they have a board with many people
from industry so I get not just the
academic perspective but also industry's
perspective ok and the view there is
that I repeat that renewable energy is
advancing very fast in spite of just a
few papers ok most others don't agree
but nuclear energy also is advancing a
lot I know that it's worrisome what you
do with waste but the amount of waste is
very small so imprint that's a soluble
problem it's a political problem where
do you put it
but in principle it's technologically
it's something that you can deal with ok
it's just the political is is
complicated but it's the new the 4th
generation nuclear the cheaper smaller
nuclear reactors that are probably going
to be relatively cheap and if indeed
there are problems that are limited
through their Bolinas to the
conventional renewables that that will
be able to help and there's one more
point just to mention it which is we
waste a lot of energy and we know that
in some places the Scandinavian
countries waste a lot less and they have
a very acceptable standard of living so
we can do a lot better without
incandescent light bulbs with efficient
air conditioning with much better
insulation so these technologies are
around the corner already and some are
already implemented ok so that's yet
another way in which the solution comes
about but given the cost of not doing
anything clearly overwhelms
the cost of the solutions that are in
the horizon already thank you that's a
way I would put you okay oh they have
the microphone hi
I'm just wondering so a few people have
proposed geoengineering methods such as
injecting sulfate aerosols into the
atmosphere to help cool the planet and
counter the effects of climate change
what are your views on those ideas okay
two points first my views yes said I
think it is all right and the scientific
community should carry out the research
but I also agree with the consensus that
before we actually implement these
measures we need to do the consult
just like we do with with the United
Nations with some international changes
since you're gonna affect the entire
planet it's not something that your
scientist should decide the world being
that you might have some unwanted side
consequences okay what will will those
be
but yes you just have to keep learning
and I just want to stress the point that
that particular geoengineering solution
was suggested that it's been advised by
Paul Crutzen by my colleague with whom
we share the Nobel Prize and I
understand some of his points namely
that you can put relatively cheaply
sulfur particles in the stratosphere
just like some volcanoes do and we know
that the temperature drops when
volcanoes explode vertically because
most of them don't but if they do and
inject in the stratosphere temperature
drops if that's happened historically
they drop one or two degrees just by one
year and the point being is something
goes terribly wrong you just stop that
and it's not something that is going to
last forever but the I guess the
counterpoint is look it's not that
difficult it was covered I guess the
Lord it's connected to the previous
question we have other solutions just
reduce emissions and those
we know that that's a natural way of
doing that there are people suggesting
yet other kinds of solutions which is to
capture co2 in the atmosphere but that's
very expensive at the moment maybe in
the future there will be ways by the way
there is also now a trend it's fusion
for many years Fusion was 50 years in
the future no matter when you were
talking about always 15 years in the
future but now there are some findings
again knife mit has made a lot of
progress here because they can have huge
magnetic fields in a very small volume
and the idea is that not next year but
within a decade with my very well
finally see fusion coming around that
that would be imagine if you have a
solution of that type without adverse
consequences then you would not need
geoengineering but by all means let's
keep exploring that just your if it
becomes really necessary thank you
question here please so I've encountered
unfortunately individuals who would
think that Oh a few changes in
temperature or Celsius when it makes
such a difference how do you approach
responding to someone to get them to
grasp the importance of even a few
temperature even a few degrees well dude
show them some of the consequences that
were already having it's not just a few
degrees that matter and in fact we
acknowledge that in some places on the
planet you you will have some benefits
but what we have seen just in the last
few years is very clear examples of
negative consequences and you can cite
many examples among them that glaciers
in the mountains are melting okay now in
principle you won't be able to to do
tourism over there and look at the nice
pieces of ice off so what no no this
matters because that's a very important
water source for agriculture in some
places or what happens is if if the
rainy season in in in in India changes
completely and they won't be able to do
agriculture the way they are doing so
it's a change part of the explanation is
that society civilization and so on has
grown in the Holocene with very few
climatic changes okay and if we have
changes that are happening very fast
it's a change itself that gives us
travel if the temperature had been a few
degrees warmer for tens of thousands of
years per civilization would have
probably evolved in in a different way
but the change and the non be unknown
nonlinearities that if you are scientist
you probably know that you suddenly
reach a threshold and suddenly things
change not smoothly but suddenly okay
the the main difficulty here because of
the complexity of the climate is that
it's very hard to predict but these
these so-called surprises okay so that
you would have just to show them by
example and that's one disadvantage of
condensing the conversation just in the
two degrees or in the temperature change
it's just one way to illustrate what I
would emphasize it's an
oversimplification to talk just about
this surface temperature change that
just one way to summarize issues but
it's not the main worry thank you please
yeah thank you so much for the great
lecture one thread that I hear that is
common to yesterday's discussion and
your lecture today is that our greatest
challenges are not scientific and
technological they are political and
cultural right would you agree that we
need more Grand Challenge initiatives
that address politics and culture yes
very much so
and let me give you two so ways in which
we can do that one way is extremely
important unfortunately not very fast
but nevertheless they're really
important and that's a change in a decay
because we have now new waste to educate
starting with with elementary school how
children learn science and there are new
ways to do that in which they learn it
very much faster much more efficiently
and it's they not only it doesn't work
much better it's much more entertaining
okay so you get the children to really
enjoy doing science but other subjects
as well how because it's the so called
active or interactive learning and that
happens also in college it happens at
all levels but in college instead of
just listening to somebody you actually
discuss you form groups and and so on
it's a it's a long story board that's
happening already at MIT and hardware
there are some of these courses and the
most important thing is that in this
fashion you can also talk about values
okay children learn to appreciate nature
then they go back to their homes and
they are the ones telling their parents
to not waste energy for example okay
because they love nature if they are
properly educated and so what one big
expectation is that the new generation
the younger generation when they get
what they need to get eventually
decision makers and so on they will be
much more responsible because
unimportant value is let's all work
together and make sure that we do things
that not just for our own personal
benefit but what for society at large
okay so that's one way but that's I I
understand that will take some time but
it's no longer waiting three or four
generations but the other way is we're
making some progress when we talk to
politicians and we sit down with them
and so on with many of them things work
we were talking about people in
government with we have Republicans but
what is amazing is Republicans from past
administrations I have many good friends
there
very eager to change they just cannot
convince many of their fellow
Republicans that are currently in
Congress okay what they are changing
already okay things are beginning to be
so clear the past changing it's not
changing at the level of the presidency
yet okay but hopefully that's temporary
for the Republican Party as you know is
changing so we think we can do it
because it makes so much sense and
because we can actually put it very
clearly on the table
what are the reasons that you don't want
to lose we know the Tea Party initially
the reason was we don't want government
interaction with anything and so
anything such as climate change we
should just discredit but that's
exaggerated obviously the government
needs to help with some measures such as
at the example I always put on the table
which is obvious now is the government
is the one responsible for removing lead
in gasoline and we say no the government
shouldn't touch what the private
industry soon how many children would
have died without that type of
government action and now air quality in
many developing countries many people
would die if the government just says no
I let I will let the private sector do
what they need to do no it's very clear
that government should act what it
should do it appropriately getting the
sectors that are affected involved in
the decisions and whatnot I hope I'm an
optimist and I think well nothing less
than the Paris Accord okay well I'm
biased because I was in pikas which is
the President's Council of Advisors in
science and technology so I work with
President Obama
I heard 20 of us and we a few of us
there were time a change sort of
scientists and we talked to him many
times and defined essentially the Paris
agreement what do I mean it was defined
in such a way that the United States
could
pass it what did that mean that means up
that means meant that US Congress had
nothing to do with the Paris agreement
because they would not have agreed with
it to me but that's changing now we hope
thank you another question please so a
lot of experts agree that agriculture is
one of the largest global emitters of
greenhouse gases and not only in that
respect but also a huge waste of water
the use of pesticides and fertilizers
some of these experts agree that a
change to permaculture might be a
solution to fixing that part of the
greenhouse gas emissions issue so to
what extent do you think that
collaboration between agriculture
scientists and climate scientists as
well as other changes for example
turning to indigenous cultures for
knowledge on how nature works without
necessarily the rigor of scientific
investigation but just inherent
knowledge of how these systems work well
I think you can you can mix it you can
if you have some ideas about some
changes in agriculture you can do
scientific tests and that that has
happened so there's it need not be
incompatible but that's a recognised
aspect of climate change it's not
necessarily the the largest or the most
important because it's again burning
fossil fuels both agriculture practices
had been part of this whole idea and in
fact that peak as I was just talking
about this group with with President
Obama we have if not one and maybe two
reports on agriculture who are we met
with experts some actually from this
University that were very much experts
on these issues and yes there are
problems excess use of fertilizers okay
that effect the nitrogen cycle and so on
so what that should be improved but it's
even more important in developing
countries where they're just wasting
resources okay so there is a lot that
can be done with agriculture to improve
the practices and again it's a huge
challenge not just because of climate
change for the
you have to feed a growing population
but fortunately I think there are
there's good science in that field which
is far from my own field but as I
understand there is progress but there
again the politics is remains to be
worked out and just give you one example
which is in Mexico for we deal with with
science policy and one of the things
we're trying to change we have not
succeeded yet is there is an incentive
in agriculture where the government
simply gives away water and electricity
and that's not very wise because then
people in business and so they don't
care they can waste water electricity
government pays for it why should we
care so we are suggesting to change the
subsidy not to remove it but to give
them the resources in in cash inclusion
in some other way
but so that they don't just waste the
water and the energy and so there are
many examples like this in the here and
in the developing world that need to be
changed with the help of science but
again we're talking a little bit about
the politics the science and the
technology thank you a quick question
from this side first please Naomi Klein
in this changes everything
says that it's capitalism versus the
climate and since emissions have really
increased under this deregulated
capitalism and a lot of industry um is
just not regulated or punished for its
over admitting do you think that we can
really make progress without changing
like the economic system that's a good
question and I think let me be very
optimistic I think we can because
capitalism is the only form of guess of
government that we know works has many
problems ok but we know that for example
the Soviet Union didn't work out before
so and and Venezuela is not working at
all and so on so
other systems have big promising what
capital is if it's properly managed if
you have the population well-informed
and the politicians responding to that
we believe it can be done and we have
many examples of industries here in the
United States that are socially
responsible and acknowledged you can
make money and still you can protect the
environment and you can make sure that
you're not doing damage to future
generations it's possible but we need to
work together ok
that's what we should do having spent 48
hours standing next to you I think
optimism is the word that best defines
you most optimistic laureate I've ever
met it's fantastic
please so a big thing I've picked up on
here is that there are a lot of
political issues back behind this that
the science is there but the politics
isn't quite there we need to be
optimistic about it but how do we get
governments go along with climate change
how do we get people to rally behind it
like you were able to rally behind the
ban of CFCs well we almost did it
we just have I think a temporal problem
now here in the States but with the with
a mantra protocol I was there we were
able to make it it worked it happened
all the countries in the world accepted
Margaret Thatcher who by the way she was
a pharmaceutical chemist okay so she was
a scientist but she very much initially
was a little post weak until she
understood everything and then with
Ronald Reagan they did it they were very
conservative governments at that time
let's talk about climate change in Paris
because that was still with President
Obama poor I was able with shake hands
with lots of heads of states they all
took a photograph 150 I don't know how
many of them they all agreed so it can
be done okay one trick is to go to high
levels but unfortunately there are
exceptions we have to be optimistic and
we have to keep working you can argue
and say Oh
society will evolve civilization will
advance no matter what let's just wait
no I would say that's alright but it
won't happen by itself
we need to be there we need to work we
need to work all together and I think we
can do it
that's my optimism thank you so much I
think I think we should stop there and
summarize your whole approaches keep
working it can be done that's right and
that seems an appropriate place to stop
so I'd like to thank you very much
indeed Maria for everything in place and
[Applause]
[Music]